okay everyone my name is Aram sabeti I'm
the founder of zero cater today I'm
going to tell you about how I started
zero kata without writing a single line
of code for the first 12 months so so
some quick background first start zero
cater about five years ago we're up to
80 employees now we're here feeding over
700 companies and we have offices in San
Francisco DC Chicago and New York
so 2007 I discover hacker news and I
become completely completely obsessed
with everything to do with startups and
I have this very romanticized idea of
sleeping under a desk and I can't wait
to start a company
so only problem is I'm 21 years old at
the time and I have no idea how to do
this so I figure the best plan is to
join a startup figure out what it's all
about
and then go do my own thing so to this
end I sell my car I get a ride to the
Bay Area and I start looking for housing
I convince this retired dentist to give
me the keys before he's gotten a
signature money or anything and I start
applying to jobs now my timing for this
could not have been better
neither came my clicker hmm
there we go so it was 2008 and nobody
was hiring and especially nobody was
hiring somebody with no particular
marketable skills so I applied to job
after job after job and got nothing so I
started applying to every job I could
find because at this point I was really
starting to run out of money and you
know I didn't still get nothing I end up
walking to downtown Berkeley and I walk
into every open door and actually ask
for a job application and as one does in
this sort of situation I got a job at
you know hmm
Ben & Jerry's fun fact
this guy eventually became a customer so
meanwhile I come across a job post for
justin.tv and I apply it's for a
community manager job and I actually get
a response back and I go through a
series of interviews and each time
anything this is the only time they did
interviews this way over the entire time
I was there but each time they would
tell us how many other candidates we
were competing with so it was like 24
people 16 people and I really started
thinking of ways you could stand out so
I tell them things like just to be fair
I should mention I'm gonna quit in a
year and start my own company this is
what you'd call a high variance strategy
and I got the call and they decide not
to hire me for that job but apparently
my startup enthusiasm had made an
impression and they decided to make a
role for me and I started a justin.tv as
the fifth employee doing office
operations now if you don't know what
office operations is it's kind of like
the junk drawer of startup jobs if
something doesn't go somewhere you throw
it to that guy and he'll take care of it
don't worry about it
so I did this for 18 months and I met a
lot of really great people I learned a
lot I went from being clueless to
slightly less clueless and it was just a
really educational experience but you
know after 18 months I started get
worried that I was stuck because I only
plan to be there for a year so I gave
myself a deadline I decided I was going
to quit my job in six months so I had to
come up with an idea and get it to Raman
profitable by then now I was living off
of less than $1,500 a month at the time
so ramen profitable was kind of a low
bar and I would do things so I didn't
forget like at a countdown timer to my
desktop and changed my work password to
six months quit
and this is this is just how it did for
a while
so I was responsible for a lot of
different things that just TV I wore a
lot of hats and of all the
responsibilities I had guess which one
was the most annoying I'll give you a
hint it rhymes with bore during brunch
now justin.tv was an extremely
opinionated about food company I mean
these guys I thought at the time was
normal but now that I've seen thousands
of companies actually they're in the top
one percentile opinionation about food
no seriously we would have email
conversations across the whole company
50 emails long about the merits of
olives and whether or not they were
disgusting all those are highly
polarizing I've learned unfortunately I
had what Paul Graham calls schlep
blindness which is where we have a
start-up idea right in front of your
face and just can't see it and to be
fair in 2009 food stars were really
considered a legit thing isn't not
really something people ever raise money
doing fortunately around this time the
office manager at Dropbox apparently
heard that if food had gotten pretty
good and she emailed a founder of
justin.tv asking for our list the list I
had come up with and around the same
time I was having this conversation with
Justin about different startup ideas I
was considering and he mentioned this
office manager and suggest that I helped
them out so three months later I quit my
job by the way I think this is a really
good recipe for start-up ideas you know
you get a job the bottom the totem pole
where they throw you all the crap nobody
wants to do I guarantee you'll find a
hair on fire a problem so this is zero
cater 1.0 I should say I should say zero
point one you'll notice it's a giant
spreadsheet you should also notice that
Dropbox is on there at 30 people the
real lesson of this whole talk is I
should have asked to be paid on equity
no seriously that Facebook graffiti guys
worth like 500 million dollars now so
for the first website I looked up a
couple simple tutorials on CSS and HTML
and made something really basic in
notepad for the company menu pages I
made a separate page and each week when
I wanted to update their menus I'd go in
and edit the HTML and upload it through
FTP my sales formula was pretty simple I
had a list of companies I wanted to talk
to I would look them up on LinkedIn look
for second and third degree connections
and then ask for deductions now this
part kind of sucked and I'm pretty sure
everybody I knew got sick of me pimping
their LinkedIn connections but there you
are so I did this for a year got to five
hundred thousand dollars a year gross
sales run rate and everything broke I'll
give you an example I was spending 20
hours a week creating invoices by hand
which is stupid I'm just there's no
reason to do this but there you are this
really sucked so this is the point where
I started really looking for a technical
co-founder and it took three months but
I convinced a friend to join and you
know at this point I'd moved to San
Francisco and my roommates were getting
a little pissed at me for running a
business out of the living room so we
got our first office it was at 8th and
Howard and it cost us $200 a month and
people smoked crack in the doorway not
even kidding
so the first thing we did was automate
this giant spreadsheet into a django app
the second thing we did was automated
billing and to this into the Django app
and we had this beautiful moment where I
clicked this button and 20 hours of work
happened in 3 seconds oh my god was
amazing so we applied to white Commodore
in the mean time and we got an interview
with Paul Jessica we sat down with them
and I actually think we got it pretty
easy
we were pretty lucky in that Paul liked
the idea right away and at one point he
asked Jessica how she felt about
ordering the catering for all these Y
Combinator events and she said she hated
it so we got the call that night I've
been accepted into the winter 2011 class
of Y Combinator so a few months into Y
Combinator I'm talking to this sales
manager that I'm trying to
recruit and I tell them our numbers and
it's kind of a pause and he asks if he
can introduce if he can introduce us to
this VC that he knows and the thing that
why commander teaches you about
fundraising is that it's an
all-or-nothing proposition so we weren't
ready to go into fundraising mode so I
really tried to push him off but he
really adamant just want to maybe this
guy had 15 minutes over coffee not okay
I'll meet him for 50 minutes so I go and
meet the guy the next day I get an email
we'd also like to know if you're willing
to go up to a million dollars now
remember I was mostly bootstrapped up at
this point and my average bank balance
for the previous year was pretty much
around $8,000 so this was a big deal
so you've probably heard of startups
referred to as an emotional
rollercoaster and I'll give you a great
example one day this guy wants to give
me a million dollars the next day my
co-founder quit and so I have a friend
who has a great saying he says startups
are like stars dude co-founder
relationships what puppies do to socks
they try to pull them apart and you know
I've never really worked with this guy
before and I hadn't felt like he was
really that invested he didn't like some
decisions I was making so we parted ways
now this happens to about a quarter of
companies they lose a co-founder and
it's actually one of the most common
reasons for a start-up to fail this is
why they try to dig into the
relationship so much in a YC interview
so here I was as a single non-technical
founder trying to raise money which
usually doesn't really go very well
fortunately this is one of my favorite
things my favorite thing about startups
traction trumps everything in
qualifications don't matter
qualifications don't matter because if
you believe you can go if you believe
you can do something you can go out and
do it and eventually if you're right
people will be forced to acknowledge
that so we raise money from the great
set of investors actually we don't raise
money from any of those VCS
but they did fun zero cater because
they've all used a zero cater we find
it's less diluting to to get money for
food instead of equity
so what's the take away for all this we
didn't raise a 1.5 million dollar seed
round so what's the takeaway there are
some quotes that I really like people
have described startups as being like
being punched in the face repeatedly
pissing blood and my favorite chewing
glass there's a great piece of slang
from world world to world war ii and
you've all heard it before snafu snafu
stands for situation normal all
up and that startups in a nutshell and
this is actually one of the most
important things to realize because if
you start a company you will inevitably
be in a situation where everything is
up and you'll probably be in many
of those situations and if you don't
understand this is just the way things
are you'll probably quit and the most
important thing that most of the biggest
existential risks your startup is you
quitting so that's really the most
important part of winning in the long
run all right guys that's it if you
interesting using zero Kader just email
at zero keto comm we're also hiring for
a lot of roles VP of Product VP of
engineering take care